thank you
[Music]
so this is really really weird there was
a 72 year old woman
who has now been arrested in a hospital
in Germany
after allegedly switching off a
patient's ventilator twice because she
didn't like the noise it was making wow
you're like God dad that's just [__]
loud dude can't hear my Netflix is she a
patient she's she's a patient she's a
pensioner but she's a yeah I believe
it's so funny patient in there oh and
this other patient was a 79 year old
patient they're like can't breathe and
[__] yeah
shut up those noises are pretty loud
though is it really are you sympathizer
what about her man
she needs to get better so she can't
sleep yeah that's true that's a huge
debate actually in the online Health
Community you can't sleep you can't
recover as well funny that the machine
is that easy to turn off I know she's
just says
she knew yeah [__] you're a patient
you're in a doctor she was like she just
saw the plug and was like oh yeah I
recognize this yeah
I know this from home I mean if you had
a bunk mate right and then they're
[__]
they're they're on life support wait
time out when are you gonna have a bunk
mate at the hospital
what are you gonna have a [__] or
like a you you got a roommate you got a
roommate at the hospital right yeah and
then you're sitting there and they're on
life support and it's going beep
beep I can't sleep and I'll [__] pull
the plugs I'm not gonna put you in the
same room as someone that's on life
support they might yeah
unfortunately they did to her yeah oh
they were in the same room
yeah I mean they definitely were close
enough
she walks by because you know a
different Wing dude she walked by and
was like oh so wait what did they do to
her
so the very very first time uh that she
did it they explained to the woman that
that patient was dependent upon the
supply of oxygen and she's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
yeah depending on getting some Z
one
we should do that so you know gave her
the benefits
whatever whatever but they had to
explain it to her and then uh the second
they uh that she did it again uh they
had to resuscitate the 79 year old
now just funny but like and he had to go
to intensive care but he's now described
as out of danger thank God okay yeah but
because now right yeah yeah because she
did it twice and was even [__]
formally notified the first time she
[__] up how like actually this was not
right
[Laughter]
those people are just like little kids
dude I'm like what they get faster
certain age yeah
sounds like a
[Music]
so she was she was brought before a
judge the next day after what she was
taken to jail ahead of a potential trial
she's like [__] how am I supposed to
get better
you're taking me to jail man you're too
loud right yeah yeah
that's a sentence does it say what she
was in the hospital for no they just
keep calling her a pensioner [__] that
yeah what is that that means she's
retired yeah and she's just collecting
uh checks yeah but in the hospital yeah
they useless
you could call her that dude for what
she did what you did was [__] really
funny just collecting money getting sick
and [__] yeah the state has to pay for
old ass and she's trying to murder
someone
two times lazy old [__] this was in uh
yeah [__] that [__] dude uh Germany
it's in Germany he's in Germany yeah and
she probably got she probably got ties
to the Nazis too [__] lazy old Nazi
[__]
immediately yeah you're tied to the
Nazis dude [__] old and lazy Chapelle
was thinking it I was thinking yeah he
was thinking I imagine we're just going
you all right
you feel good to be back oh you're dying
oh you're dying
my feelings
[Laughter]
oh [__] this is
if found guilty of attempted
manslaughter utter the 72 year old could
spend several years behind bars great
[Laughter]
years of her life right
right yeah
um there was a there was a case where a
61 year old T Scott Marr had been rushed
to the hospital and was unresponsive but
still breathing so they put him on a
ventilator and then when somebody had
switched off the ventilation is when he
came back to life so they considered him
the Miracle Man oh maybe that's what she
was trying to do
[Laughter]
unplugs the ventilator she was really
trying to kill him she would just turn
it up on like extra high yeah extra
yeah
like he's turning up like a radio
all right let's turn up the volume
that is crazy she's kind of gangster
though you don't [__] around like what
she's a Nazi dude she's like it's too
loud they might need to cover up the
buttons on the machines on no yeah or
something why is she doing
and so her excuse was that it was just
too noisy yeah that was literally you
know what my theory is on this lady she
wasn't sick at all dude she's a
pensioner they don't say what she's got
I don't think I think she was not sick
at all and I think she was just chilling
hard at the hospital I think she's an
assassin oh working for the Führer she's
finally activated
I think she would have just been a baby
during that time or or she's an angel oh
yeah you ever think of that oh yeah more
like the Grim Reaper
look at me I mean maybe she was just
like hey God wants you now she's like
it's your time yeah it's your time
Reaper yeah they turned the thing back
on she's like oh man I gotta make up an
excuse that's just annoying hey God
imagine though being a person that
hooked up to a machine and you see
somebody flip it off and you can't do
nothing [__] yeah you're just like come
on
I need that [__] I should kill you what
do you think is the time when they when
when
um old people start becoming more and
more like children what age do you think
you mean when they start putting on
diapers and drinking Insurance stuff and
start [__] talking like kids
I think 80s yeah around there's some 80
year olds that are like chilling yeah
yeah yeah sharks attack that's true it's
really dependent it's it's kind of like
uh that moment where you know even from
like a a taking care like a welfare or
or a financial point of view you know in
that moment when your parents are paying
for your [__] and taking care of you and
then there's that middle where
everybody's adults and then suddenly
you're in a spot where you're taking
care of your parents and paying their
bills I'm assuming when they're being
taken care of by you they also get to
flip off a couple other switches as well
at the same time he is make sure make
sure they keep working till they die
yeah yeah so then they never get but
that's what they say about over people
like if you don't usually you lose it
that's true yeah yeah like your
cognitive function if you're not like do
it that's why they always tell old
people older people to like do like
crossword puzzles that's why they keep
buying them we use yeah well my my
stepdad's 88 but Apple's still trying to
pitch people for business 88 yeah 88 he
sucks at it oh yeah
we I had Dave we had a little barbecue
in Hawaii David came through and then
David was talking to him and then I was
giggling because I was all like all
right
um he has no idea what he's getting
himself into so I just kind of watched
and David like he's a good Asian boy so
he's respectable you know he just like
listens intently like he he doesn't like
act like he's bored or nothing so I'm
like oh he actually likes this
conversation
he'll tell you a [__] story
and at the end you don't know that he's
trying to pitch you something and then
at the end he'll go
so how do you think and we're like what
do you mean when I you want to invest in
this business
he's a master pitch
perfect so so right now he's doing this
thing where he's trying to help his
buddy sell these uh fishing lures that
shocks the fish oh yeah so then once the
fish gets shot it could reel it in so
you see how I could tell this pitch in
like 30 seconds right it'll take this
dude 20 minutes
so uh if you go fishing
and you get tuna fish
you get the lure and The Lure The Lure
shocks the fish have you seen that
before that's how he talks this guy's 88
yeah he sounds like the guy from uh Star
Trek yeah yeah it sounds like and then
you get this
and once you the fisherman does not have
resistance when he reels it in
we're just sitting there like dude how
slow can you sing yo how yo is he
killing me
quite a few times I think I'm in say
that to him yeah and then right after be
like I got 50 bucks on it that's true
all right see what happens because there
are things that you become familiar did
well so like 10 years ago or a little
bit more he um so he was traveling to
the Philippines going back and forth and
then he created a non-profit
organization worked with the Japanese
government and he helped Filipino nurses
come to Japan
um and and get jobs that's pretty cool
yeah suddenly this who's got credibility
that that sounds normal right so so
during that he he made friends in the
Philippines right and the more he
explains it to me they sound kind of
connected to underground gangster [__]
and then he shows me pictures they look
kind of Gangsta like they have these
parties and stuff
yeah right
they have they have security he says
they're they're dangerous so he has
security they look like thugs with guns
you know really and then so he tells me
that his friends can get tuna for a very
cheap price and I'm like oh that's
interesting right and the more I think
about it I'm like they sound like
illegal fishing peoples because they do
that pirates do that like you're not
it's illegal you gotta fish it in
special Waters and then they're like
charging like half the price for tuna
which is crazy so I was like I think
you're getting yourself involved in some
dangerous [__] here and he goes no they
know politicians and I'm like yeah but
like gang's there no politics yeah
exactly like what are you talking about
what's the homies that chop the fingers
off
yeah
the Filipino Yakuza yeah
dude yeah
yo that's just wild
[Music]